estimados maestros y maestras del perú
año tras año hemos sido testigos de cómo
la educación ha ido evolucionando hacia
un entorno digital hoy es prácticamente
una necesidad que como maestros tengamos
las habilidades necesarias para
desarrollar una correcta práctica
educativa a distancia en beneficio de
todos nuestros estudiantes por ello los
invito a postular a la reja maestro
canal caribe y 2021 donde podrán acceder
a diversos recursos y capacitaciones que
nos ayudarán en su empoderamiento como
maestros y en sus clases a distancia
recuerden que solo tienen hasta el 3 de
más para mandar sus postulaciones
contamos de ustedes
aquí